so last week the presiding judge in the
derrick chauvin trial chastised one of
the witnesses one of the first
responders i will determine when your
answer is done
okay well do not argue with the court do
not argue with counsel
answer the questions do not volunteer
information that is not requested
many people reached out and said that
they thought that the judge was
chastising witness and was interfering
in the process
actually this is much more common and
not very controversial a witness has to
answer the questions that are presented
to them the opposing attorneys have an
opportunity to
get the other information that they want
out of the witness later on and that's
why in cross-examination you're allowed
to ask
leading questions but when you're on the
witness stand the witness should just
answer the questions posed and not
trying to interject additional
information and that's what the judge
thought this witness was doing so
this was not something that was out of
hand this is not unusual judges do this
all the time they really just want the
child to proceed in an orderly fashion
and for all the attorneys to be able to
ask all the questions that they need to
to get the facts out that they need so
stay tuned for more coverage of the
chauvin trial and i'll see you
in court